we start the program with some breaking
news both the Reuters news agency as
well as the AFP are quoting the iaea to
report that Iran has increased the
amount of uranium it's enriching to near
weapons grade levels they quote a report
by the U.N nuclear Watchdog the
international atomic energy agency
saying enrichment up to 60 has grown by
more than 12 kilograms let's go straight
to our correspondent daughter Jabari
who's in Tehran Joseph this is indeed
true it is significant talk us through
exactly what it means
well this means that the world's nuclear
Watchdog the international atomic energy
agency is not able to do its job and
provide assurances to the International
Community that Iran's nuclear program is
exclusively a civilian one it's used for
peaceful purposes the iea is going to
have the Board of Governors meeting on
Monday September 12th they have one
every three months and during this Board
of Governors meeting there is a report
that is put forth every time by the
agency about their ongoing activities
and of course the Iran nuclear file is
usually at the top of that report this
time around as a result of a number of
events that have unfolded between the
agency's cooperation and Iranian
officials the agency is now saying in
this report that has been seen by those
two agencies news agencies that you
mentioned that according to them they're
no longer able to provide reassurances
that this country's nuclear program is
for a purely civilian purposes is they
haven't been able to get the access that
they wanted they also haven't received
sufficient responses from Iranian
officials about three specific
Undeclared sites where the agency has
found traces of uranium activity that
dates back to the years of early years
of 2000s the Iranian officials for their
part say they have sufficiently
responded to those inquiries and that
the
re-digging up of those issues the agency
is coming up with now about those three
sites is as a result of political
pressure from Israel and as a result of
intelligence provided by Israel and
other countries that don't want to see
Iran in a position to be able to
negotiate a proper return to that 2015
nuclear deal now what is at stake here
is that retrieve Revival of the 2015
nuclear deal according to the agency's
report that is due out later today to
the board members Iran now has a
stockpile 19 times the limit that it was
allowed out under the 2015 nuclear deal
meaning Iran's high in Rich uranium is
above the levels that they agreed to in
2015 under that agreement Iran was
allowed to store
212 202 kilograms of 3.67 percent in
Rich uranium now since the United States
left the deal in 2018 and imposed a
series of unilateral sanctions on Iran
the officials here step by step withdrew
their commitments under that deal and
keeping a stockpile of a highly enriched
uranium was one of those steps they took
meaning all this time they are now
adding to their enriched uranium
stockpile which is staying in the
country this is one of the main concerns
of the agency and the International
Community
we understand that the negotiations that
have been ongoing for many months to
trying to get back to the deal was these
are some of the issues that are at the
core of those uh discussions taking
place which have yet to be resolved as
you say that nuclear deal very much at
stake what do you think is going to
happen now
well there's a lot of uh skepticism
inside Iran at the moment about whether
or not this deal is salvageable at this
stage there has been a lot of back and
forth between the Iranian officials and
the Americans about a draft proposal the
European Union officials have put forth
to the two sides to try and bring them
all back to full compliance under the
deal the iaea plays a crucial part in
this because they are the police in all
of this to be able to monitor any kind
of agreements that they would have
between Iran and the International
Community about its nuclear program and
since
2019 that Iran started reducing its
compliance they haven't been able to do
their job properly and this report is
one of the most damning that we've seen
from the agency and certainly concerning
the iea's general director Raphael
Grossi has said that they won't be able
to do their job properly in terms of
monitoring Iran's nuclear activities if
there is no return to this nuclear deal
and it seems that uh right now that is
exactly where things are at and the
Iranian officials are adamant that until
the United States agrees to their terms
and returns to their end of the bargain
that they agreed to and more after what
they did in 2018 the Iranians will not
agree to come back to the deal because
they're afraid the Americans will do the
same again in when there's another
election in the United States and
another Administration in Washington
Dulce Jabari there for us in Tehran
thank you